bravo bravo au président lorrain je
repense thierry notre ami cortier veut
que tout à l'heure le bon vieux temps du
double jeu
c'est vrai que cette émission avait au
moins un avantage c'est qu'à cette
époque vous traitiez correctement les
invités alors que l'âge de suis un petit
peu attristé de voir que maintenant vous
aviez tout à l'heure la chance d'avoir
christian bujeau vous l'avais un peu
traitée au débotté
je ne sais pas ce qui vous arrive mais
vraiment vous les traitez comme quantité
négligeable
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'aille
leur servir la soupe aux invités c'est
ça que vous voulez professeur au moins
ça thierry suire servir la soupe
d'accord marc quand tu viens fabien tu
viens
[Musique]
le
c'est lui
[Musique]
et
je
c'est parce qu'il n'arrivait vraiment
l'état des dettes quantité négligeable
qu'est-ce que vous
j'ai versé revient à sucre
anglet fini la salue jacques soir son
soin bonsoir oui merde on est en retard
on voulait choper la sortie de scène et
tout coûte en plus on dit toujours que
je traite mal mais invité l'acheteur et
amener les souvenirs beaucoup de servir
la soupe
en plus c'est pas l'air con qu'est ce
qu'on va faire je prends ta valise r on
peut aller berthier hollande au berkeley
alors à boire un coup allez mourir un
levier avec ta soupe toi donc c'est la
150e son 50e ouais mais tu vas rester là
jusqu'à quand là on va de toute façon
maintenant jusqu'à fin mai et on joue
une fois par semaine on fait le mardi
après midi à 15h30 tarifs
je vais dire tout le bien que je pense
de cette pièce sera que je te tuer
menace ou pour moi j'adore ça
là on va écouter alors il ya un serveur
externe et sa fille louise qui a déjà
qui c'est là où je jouerai venait
bonsoir soir bonsoir
bon goût de cette soupe alors on va voir
le souffle j'adore la souris c'est lui
qui s'avance pas c max est venu pour
servir la soupe mais celui qui sert la
soupe avérée un peu de soupe
on dit que c'est pas sympa moi j'ai vu
la pièce hier soir et je trouve que
cette pièce donc elle est drôle dans son
maire pas une seconde en fin et je sais
pas si les gens enfin c'est bourré tu me
diras même si la 150e donc des pâtes et
mon problème mais je sais pas il faut
dire aux gens qu'on se marre qu'on
rigole que consomme a pas une seconde et
tout est est ce que c'est bien passé ça
ce que tu viens de dire ouais c'est bien
passé la façon dont il dit est ce que
c'est bien passé dans les médias est ce
que les gens ils ont dû suite royale en
costume de diderot crébillon
c'est qu'elles sont pas dit que ça va
être un peu cyan et non parce que je
crois que enfin séparé répondait c'est
comment je trouve que tout ce qu'on a
fait justement c'était pour amener un
autre public
une saga qui yade au départ d'une pièce
quand une pièce commence il ya toujours
pendant 10 15 représentations le vrai
public des amoureux du théâtre
de toute façon les yeux fermés vient et
après il se répand dans tout paris pour
dire voilà comment c'est moins bien et
bien debout alors c est et en plus cela
il ya un miracle avec le marigny c'est
qu'il ya les trois sortes de public
il ya ceux qui lisent les critiques il
ya ceux qui viennent par le bouche à
oreille et puis y'a des gens qui ont
jamais mis les pieds dans une salle de
classe et qui viennent parce qu'il ya
des prix de places demi-tarif le mardi
après-midi ou parce que c'est des gens
qui justement n'ont pas le l'idée que
c'est du duc réunion du 10 mai au qui
viennent là comme pour dj lewis et c'est
ça c'est c'était le pari de sa série
google de présenter un tas rigoler oui
non mais j'étais très très très heureux
ce monsieur on s'éclate on défonce le
fait bien 10 trop vieux ou là à les
regarder et suissa qui dit ça les
arrange fait presque rap mais librement
1 parce qu'il faut sortir de l'idée que
le seul théâtre réservé à une élite de
jeu c'est pas vrai
il n'y a pas besoin d'être cultivé pour
lire la bible il ya un besoin d'être
d'être cultivé de connaître la langue du
xviiie pour la comprendre pas du tout en
mer c'est que c'est comme la musique de
mozart c'est aussi beau que le rap c'est
c'est simple et bonne la soupe
elle est bonne à ce moment moi je suis
content c'est bon appétit mais ça les
bonnes merci alors tous les soirs après
le après le marigny vous venez ici c'est
ça soit on vient au berkeley selon vos
val d'isère il ya roland il ya tout le
monde sait la cadre extraordinaire ce
qui tu vois un truc de dingue wali et
des photos sa cote des toits alors
qu'étienne chez brésilienne quel effet
ça se fait quand on met brésilienne quel
effet ça fait de se retrouver en train
de jouer du duc à billom fils
c'est vrai qu'on m'a dit qu'il va faire
et j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
francis était la seule brésilienne qui
joue du crédit en fils pas être en
intérim à 10,18 il s'agit de ma mère je
crois qu'on en a quelques-unes des fois
frais du poète fait plaisir à voir
non c'est vrai on consent une complicité
comme ça entre fait très plaisir à voir
c'est un vrai bonheur de voir
c'est vrai
je suis allé aux belles émissions de
france pourquoi pas parce que il
m'attend je veux ya des traits de la
cassette toi non t'as plus rien ça va
encore un peu je vais continuer et on va
gizon on va jusqu'à fin mai je vais
retourner avec ma femme je les appelais
j'ai déjà vu la pièce et que c'était
très bien elle m'a dit mais la prochaine
fois tu ravec projet la victoire à
bientôt
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux